[Music]
they have been fined by the police for
breaking the very lockdown laws they
introduced but should the prime minister
and the chancellor now quit you get your
say
[Music]
and we're all encouraged to walk to
school but why is there now concern
about our safety meyer investigates it
can be a matter of life or death
[Music]
welcome to fyi the weekly news show
where you get to have your say on some
of the big issues and our mission is to
help us all get our heads around the
latest news and we've heard a lot of
news about war crimes in ukraine but
what are they we've been investigating
so it turns out even if a leader thinks
attacking a country is justified there
are rules about what you can and can't
do it's all down to international laws
about warfare that most countries
including russia and ukraine have agreed
to follow
one of those rules is that citizens in a
country who don't have anything to do
with the fighting must be protected by
all sides we found out that russia is
being accused of attacking and killing
ukrainian citizens in towns and cities
they are fighting for this is what is
known as a war crime
it's also alleged that a ukrainian
soldier shot a russian soldier who was a
prisoner in war prisoners are also
supposed to be protected
the united nations and other independent
investigators are now investigating and
those responsible could end up on trial
at a special international court if
there's enough evidence to support the
allegations
meet patron a two-year-old jack muscle
terrier from ukraine but he's no
ordinary dog he's been trained to save
lives video showing patron using his
incredible notes to sniff out explosives
left by russian soldiers has made him a
social media hit
patron has discovered 90 explosives
since the start of the war what a good
boy
so the two most important people in the
uk the prime minister and the chancellor
have both apologized after being fined
by the police for breaking lockdown
rules
rules that boris johnson introduced
himself to protect us all from covert
right so most of us followed these falls
and stayed indoors and avoided
get-togethers we didn't see our families
mates those who were sick or celebrate
our birthdays and christmas together
because of these rules
as you can imagine there have been calls
for these men to quit but they say that
they need to focus on doing their jobs
at a very difficult time for the country
so we wanted to get your shout out on
this we got hold of some fy news club
members from across the uk
hi guys
so we do know that the chancellor and
the prime minister have both broke
covered rules but do you think that they
should resign
i do think that it should be up to the
public to decide in a vote
whether they should or not
yeah i agree that like
a one-off maybe is a fine but
if he kept doing it then
not really that good because we couldn't
really see the loved ones that were like
in hospital die in
now of course if they did resign the
current party leading which are the
conservatives would have to elect a new
leader if
the party were to decide for the next
prime minister
they might not choose one that we all
would like to follow
so we should probably wait for
the next election yeah i do think we
should wait for a vote maybe we should
have an early one
yeah i think it's a bit dodgy if we like
choose a new leader right now yeah we
should wait until the ukraine war is
over
well thank you very much guys
bye
[Music]
right time to get your beady eyes on two
slightly dodgy looking news stories we
know that one of them is definitely fake
but which one
[Music]
so is this dress really made from silk
produced by exotic spiders according to
a viral social media post it took five
years for a team of over 60 people to
collect enough silk from the spiders to
make this very rare and very expensive
dress are they spinning a web of lies or
is it fact
now google loves a doodle to mark a
special day in the calendar like this
one
but loads of people took to social media
to complain that while the search engine
created a doodle to mark the mostly holy
month of ramadan it didn't for the
christian holiday of easter
details of how to spot fake news are on
our website and we'll reveal which story
is fake later
so hannah got in touch with us with a
story and like many of you she's
observing the holy month of ramadan
where muslims worship by praying and
don't eat or drink during the day known
as fasting so it all climaxes with the
eid festival which marks the end of
fasting so not everyone is old enough to
fast and of course not all of us are
muslims but hannah wanted to show us
ways that everyone can get involved this
was her world during ramadan
[Music]
ramadan is a time where you can do good
deeds it helps you think about other
people rather than yourself
sunrise to sundown we don't eat eat or
drink anything and then after that we
get we can have whatever we want and we
have iftar which is
um
the meal
after you fasted and then sahari which
is the meal you have in the morning
when you're fasting it's like
you're very relaxed during it and like
you don't have to worry about anything
and it helps you focus on smaller things
that you might not notice a lot of time
also it challenges you a little bit but
you don't try it
you're gonna make a mess
also in ramadan is like when you get to
try different things
so like painting or baking or different
things like that we also
raise money for charities and donate
things
so last year we gave food to the food
bank
it makes me feel good that like i'm
helping out
you're enjoying that aren't you
because you made 12 cupcakes
your favorite
a full moon yeah then
last
quarter
food waste generally grows up in ramadan
because every day people make a new meal
so things that we can do to help reduce
food waste in ramadan
is use the food waste that you have to
make an extra meal
so um
if you have any leftover meat or
vegetables you can put it in a moroccan
herrera soup
and it's also a great chance to be
creative with what you have
during eid it's basically a time
where you bond with your family members
and just to have lots of fun
go on
in the morning on eid we go to the
mosque and we do the eid prayers and
that's like everyone goes to it and
after that we all go to see everyone and
just have fun there
you can just wear pretty dresses and
outfits so that you can have a great day
with your family
i think it would be a really good thing
for people who are not muslim to try
ramadan or eid because especially
joining in with everyone and seeing how
we
do things because lots of different
people celebrate differently and it'll
be just fun to join in with the
celebrations coming down with my lantern
that looks really nice nice one hannah
now if you have a story something you
want to speak up about or you just love
debating and investigating the big
stories like we do then why not get your
teacher to help you set up an fyi news
club at your school you'll get access to
the latest episodes of fyi free
resources every week to go with each
program
and fyi news club members will have the
chance to have their say and even report
on fyi if you have a story about you or
an issue that affects you let us know
and we could even help you film your
report and show it here on fyi just head
to our webpage for more details on how
to set up your fyi news club
[Music]
so on this street there's an invisible
house
look more carefully and you might just
see it
this mirrored house in london has been
hiding in plain sight with people who
live locally saying they've only just
noticed it
we also found this video of chinmay
prabhu from india taking multitasking to
a whole new level
chin may skydived 13 000 feet
while solving this tetrahedron puzzle in
just 24.88 seconds
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're constantly encouraged to walk
to school if we can i mean it helps us
keep us fit it protects the environment
and so much more but we've run into a
little problem haven't we yeah exactly i
mean walking to school is really great
for the environment and for keeping fit
i walk to and from school but i do find
myself looking at my phone quite a lot
which is really dangerous well that's
exactly why the weekly newspaper first
news has launched a campaign to try and
get us all to pour phones in our pockets
and look up on the wall to school
some of you entered a competition to
design a campaign poster and these are
the winning designs pretty cool they get
the message across those of us who walk
to school but are glued to our
smartphones are known as smumbies but
just how much of an issue is it and what
can be done to make that healthy walk to
school safer maya has been investigating
now we all know that these help us keep
safe stay connected with friends and
families and can even reveal our
whereabouts for worried parents
but new statistics show that they also
play a role in injuring and even killing
us
cases of zombies or smartphone zombies
have been on the rise over the last
decade and with it so have road
incidents
the most recent road safety figures show
that 6
200 pedestrians were killed or had
life-changing injuries on uk roads
1415 were aged 17 or under that surround
a whole class of pupils every week
and almost half of all road accidents
happen between 3 pm and 6 pm when we're
traveling home from school so what's
going on
well researchers from the university of
lincoln observed pupils outside a
secondary school over four weeks out of
3 000 crossings made by pupils 31 of the
time students were holding a phone or
another device
while there are so many safety measures
in place right outside our schools such
as low speed limits zebra crossings and
signs to make drivers aware none of
these actually make us look up from our
phones and some of these rules were
created in the 1950s
with more of us being encouraged to walk
to school safety campaigners want to see
more protection for us throughout our
journey maybe this could be a solution
check out these smart crossings they've
been trialled all over europe the lights
prompt walkers to look up when they get
near a road i got to meet andrew the
inventor
the system will intervene and highlight
the danger it's like an early warning
system
to the either the driver or
you guys so in other words by adding
these small led lights into a road
surface it could make people pay
attention before an accident happens so
how does this technology work well the
computer watches the street and can
identify the difference between cars
pedestrians and other road users over
time the technology is able to learn
what the different road users may do and
predict what could be about to happen
when it notices a potentially dangerous
situation it will light up special
lights in the road to alert the
pedestrian car or other road user to try
and avoid a crash we have just started
our public trials and our results to
date are
really positive we are showing that we
our intervention
our technology in the crossings are
making people safe but it's very early
days but don't expect to see smart
crossings at school near you just yet
back in 2019 the government announced
they wanted to do more research into the
connection between road accidents and
zombies before they decide what to do
the government's department of transport
didn't want to talk to us about the
issue
but the party not in power did
this is shadow transport secretary
louise hague from labour party what
would she do if her party were in power
firstly we could introduce 20 mile an
hour and limits around schools because
you know a lot of the schools are on
busy junctions they're on really um
congested roads so i think we need to
drastically reduce um their speeding
limit put in more crossings uh put in
better lighting particularly as you say
in those darker winter months um and
have proper awareness campaigns so
people are more considerate when driving
around schools
for now it's up to our schools to
protect us from the dangers of walking
to and from school
but it's up to us to stay safe
that includes the message of look up it
can be a matter of life
or death
[Music]
so let's reveal the fake story of the
week
could it be the dress made from silk
produced by exotic
spiders nope it's fact
golden orb spiders produce a web of silk
and millions of them were farmed to
produce this one-off dress it took five
years so don't expect to see these at a
shop near you
so the social media complaints about
google's doodles ignoring the christian
holiday of easter is fake the search
engine says it never marks religious
festivals this doodle mark in the muslim
festival of ramadan was created and
posted by a campaign group to put
pressure on google to use it which they
haven't
well across the world millions of people
of all faiths have been marking various
religious festivals
it's been a busy month so we're going to
leave you guys with some great photos
that we've found from all around the
world see you next week
[Music]
[Music]
you